beneath the streets of stockholm sweden
is the world's longest
did it work
am i on
oh great
good morning viewers of great big story
my name is dabchik and i've accommodated
your regular viewing to speak my truth
and empower the people to entertain
themselves during this time how by
teaching you how to create colorful
little finger puppets that you can make
fun little performances with uh from
home you might not be able to go to the
theater or cinema during this time but
if you have some post-it notes scissors
sticky tape and a little creativity you
may well be able to create something
wonderful so so let's begin okay so grab
a post-it note and laminate its surface
using sticky tape this will make it nice
and durable then cut a strip of that and
tape it around this part of your index
finger make sure it's not too loose or
too tight and that you can still bend
your finger cool now we make a similar
part for the same section of the pinky
finger you can add tape on the inside
joint as well for extra strength and
trim off the excess to make it nice and
tidy okay bye matilda
i think she's uh spotted something
oh squirrel oh too slow matilda uh check
out the action replay so her butt
smacked into the rose bush alerting him
to her presence and she just couldn't
close the distance bad luck matilda but
let's be honest you wouldn't have known
what to do if you caught him anyway
shut up okay so now we make similar
pieces for the middle sections of the
middle and ring finger and then we go
back to the pinky and index finger and
make similar pieces for their middle
segments we've got a fair few segments
now so do feel free to label them on the
inside if that helps you also do keep up
your supply of laminated post-it notes
because we've got some bigger pieces
coming we're now making a kind of long
cone that fits the middle finger you can
cut out a little section as well if it
helps it bend better then roll out
another one for your ring finger just
like you're rolling a big old doobie
have a bang on that machine don't do
drugs tricky bit now make two more
finger doobies and fix them at an angle
to the lower pieces on the index and
pinky fingers do go ahead and shave a
bit off the back if it aids the movement
and here's how it's looking so far
just need a uh just need a body slash
face now so let's go ahead and cut some
rounded slits out of a fresh post-it
note i might actually need them a little
bit longer actually then stick those
flaps to the top sections of the index
and pinky finger and tidy up those sharp
corners oh dear matilda's getting bored
don't worry we're nearly done now we
make a little cut here and we stick
either side of that to the top segments
of the ring and middle finger draw some
eyes on it and what do you know
it's finished
[Music]
well he's still a little bit unsteady on
his pins but fear not in a few short
moments he will be dancing his way into
your hearts in a little musical piece
that we've put together called the
quarantine waltz
enjoy
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
alrighty
i think that was all right
[Music]
my hands get so sweaty in these gloves
[Music]
you